now Libya's fragile ceasefire is in
doubt after warring sides failed to
reach a breakthrough during eight hours
of talks in the Russian capital so the
warlord Khalifa Haftar did not sign a
deal formalizing the truce but Moscow
says the talks are not dead however the
outcome has angered Turkey's president
recep tayyip erdogan is accusing
half-thought of running away from the
negotiations and he had this warning for
half Dutch forces in the coming days we
will carefully monitor the choices that
will be made between hafter and the
legitimate government if half tars
attacks against the people in the
government of Libya continue we will
never refrain from teaching him the
lesson he deserves well Russia which
supports half-charged campaign says will
continue to push for negotiations over
violence but there have been reports of
half-charged forces gathering in
southern Tripoli threatening the truce
that was brokered by Turkey and Russia
earlier this week so we have three
correspondents covering the rapid
development Mohammed Abdullah head is in
Tripoli jamal al is in the Turkish
capital Ankara but first let's get an
update from Stuyvesant in Moscow so step
when Moscow says that the talks are not
dead
what are they basing that on and so what
happens next
well the reen after not giving any
explanation for most of the day why have
two suddenly left Moscow without signing
the agreement now the Ministry of
Defense has released a statement in
which it says that after positively
reacted to the final agreement the draft
agreement on the ceasefire and that he
wants two days to discuss this with his
allies in Libya meaning the local tribes
they also said that the main outcome of
the talks on Monday are that both
parties have agreed to this indefinite
ceasefire and they also say that this
all has created a positive atmosphere
heading into these talks in Berlin which
are scheduled to so far still for
January 19 and they also mentioned that
these inter Libyan problems that have
piled up over the years need thorough
work so this is interesting because our
earlier Minister of Foreign Affairs
Sergey Lavrov had a very short statement
didn't mention anything about a new
deadline he was just saying that the
talks were inconclusive so something
must have happened in the last couple of
hours so the work has been continuing
behind the scenes and this must have
been a new agreement or a new statement
coming from hafta agreeing on this two
days deadline I also spoke to the head
of the Russian a Libyan contact group
here in Moscow who was actually in the
talks yesterday for eight hours and I
asked him what actually went wrong and
he said well after came up with some new
conditions at the last minute bringing
them to the table he said it's nothing
to be worried about he was very
convinced that he will sign eventually
when I asked when this will happen he
said he can't say exactly when so now we
have this this two-day deadline
okay stop fussing thank you for that
update from Moscow let's bring in jamal
al he's joining us from the turkish
capital ankara and earlier on earlier on
accused half-thought of quote running
away from the negotiations what are we
to read into Irwin's comments well he
wants to show the international
community that it is after and afters
allies who are to blame for any
resumption in fighting for the
instability that continues in libya and
at the same time show that it is his
political efforts and those of the
Turkish leadership that are trying to
establish some sort of peace and push
for a political solution the reality is
that that's what has developed over the
past 24 hours at least in the sense that
the recognized government of Tripoli the
internationally recognized government of
Tripoli which turkey backs has agreed
and has signed on the paper which
stipulates having an open-ended
ceasefire and working towards a
political solution and the ones that
haven't have been the other side namely
that of hanifa after obviously that put
the Russians in a precarious situation
because they've supported after so much
both financially and through sending
mercenaries militarily but they are not
alone in terms of
sponsoring after's project in libya
there is the United Arab Emirates and
Egypt who obviously have their own
considerations as well Turkey's
president insists that things must go on
as they have been planned and as we
heard there had a warning if that
doesn't happen that he wouldn't hesitate
to ensure that turkey responds to any
attack by half there's forces okay Jamil
thank you for that update from Ankara
let's now find out how this is all
impacting on the ground in Libya I'm
bringing my Anwar head he's joining us
from Tripoli so what is happening on the
ground as all of this takes place
outside of the Libyan capital Mahmoud
will there in it's quite on the front
lines but it is still very tense like I
said earlier we're getting reports from
government military sources saying that
half those forces are now sending
reinforcements and repositioning
regrouping in certain axes in southern
Tripoli but part of the reason why the
peace talks have been derailed in Moscow
is that as you know during that after
has been supported by regional and local
allies and those allies here for example
in Libya they include the remnants of
the former regime of Muammar al-gaddafi
and they have been very hopeful relying
on hefter to impose the military rule
intae in case he takes control of
Tripoli in the country so that they can
reinstate the regime of Muammar Gaddafi
within afters to tell Italian rule also
cities hear certain cities and tribes in
Libya they have been investing and after
they have been promised to be part of
the new Libya led by Hefner and triple a
for instance that city after una the
major supporter of Hefner here just
about 80 kilometers to the east southern
east of the Libyan capital Tripoli it's
the major supporter of Hefner here in
fact it has a central command running
the battles in southern Tripoli this
city only 24 hours ago the elderly
council in that city issued a state
blaming Hester for what they call going
to Moscow without consulting them so
this now because hefter now demanded a
longer time to consult his allies I
believe that he will definitely consult
his local allies and also regionalised
as you know Egypt and the United Arab
Emirates are the major supporters of
after the United Arab Emirates for
example has been investing a lot at
hazard over the past four years
providing Hector's with all in that
Vanson weapons aircrafts drones in fact
it has an airbase in the east eastern
region of Libya so Egypt along with
United Arab Emirates the fact that
they're supporting the what is so-called
the counter revolutions in the Middle
East they don't want any partnership
would have to for example the eastern
although the Western can't let by Suraj
which represents a majority of Libya
they do not want in fact a partnership
would have to do what Hector has to tell
it a totalitarian regime right to impose
the military rule Olivia okay
thank you for bringing us right up to
speed from Tripoli
let's now speak to Brahimi free hat he's
an associate professor specializing in
conflict resolution at the Doha
Institute joining us here on set hi
there thanks for your time with us on
the news hours so what could be
happening right now behind the scenes
for the Russians to come out and say
well hang on a second have two needs two
days to discuss and decide yeah well I
think after is under tremendous pressure
and from many different sources there is
his main supporter in Abu Dhabi the
United Arab Emirates who's funding him
from day one and this in his operation
against the tripoli and there is also
his local allies in whether its center
Hoonah or and other places but also
there is another party that also a key
player in this crisis which is Europe
that has been also and neutralized in
the Moscow talks what I call here Moscow
what most is trying to do is try to do
this unilateral
and aside or independently from Europe
so there is the preparation for the
Berlin conference that should take place
soon and we're after and Saroj be part
of this so and here comes Moscow is it
trying to do this independently from
Europe from the United Arab Emirates
from his local allies so after is under
tremendous pressure is trying to consult
all these parties before he signs franc
which is not an easy task because also
he is if he says no he will come under
the pressure of you know from Moscow
that Moscow has been a key partner a key
ally for him in the past and now now
there is the Russian mercenaries that
they're fighting with him on the ground
right from Vagner company and several
other security companies but and also in
the past when he ran into financial
crisis and in his economy Russia was the
party to to allow him to print his money
notes in Moscow and and Russia is key
player in the whole conflict because
with the Russian intervention
Russia Russia shifts the balance of
power so he can't afford to say no to
Russia ok but on the note of Russia yes
what does Russia do next because when
they brought half that in Suraj to
Moscow to reportedly sign a deal and
come up with this breakthrough it didn't
happen so does it put Russia in a
precarious position and does it continue
to support half that on the ground well
it if he says no then he has many
questions that he will have to answer to
Russia because Russia this is a very
determine ttle moment for their
intervention in Libya which has taken
very seriously but what is their endgame
in Libya the endgame in Libya there is
in my view is only a sort of an
agreement a reconciliation between all
the parties because you cannot eliminate
one party over the other because that's
what after is trying to do by the way of
the conditions that have to listed in in
the Moscow talks like for example
keeping or recognizing his forces in the
south of Tripoli and also at some point
he refused to talk to the Tripoli
government because in his view if I sign
agreements with Tripoli
then I am recognizing them and the House
of Representative is not recognizing the
the Tripoli government so he is trying
to impose his conditions in this and
that the government in Tripoli must
answer to this now Russia realizing that
what would change the whole the whole
scene dream is that the Turkish
agreement security agreement with with
the Tripoli and that Russia so turkey is
intervening in this and trying to shift
the balance of power on the ground so
that why Russia had to step in and try
to bring all the parties together and
come up with a solution that suits their
interests and does not leave Tripoli
only for Turkey who signed the agreement
with you know with the government and
also neutralize their the Russia's
rivals Europe and that's why he is
trying to bring everyone under most
custom and to when one last point on
this is that in the agreement that
they're negotiating now the
implementation of it the people who are
in charge of of the implementation will
will have to be meeting in Moscow which
also means not only the agreement under
Moscow stairs but the implementation as
well and this is a key factor in any
agreement the difference between signing
argument and the implementation that
could be where the challenges and most
codes are trying to control that as well
okay
we'll leave it there we thank you very
much for your analysis